attitude has been called the most
important word in any language in the
world you see the average man believes
some businesses are better than others
instead of realizing the truth that
there are no bad businesses just one
great idea can completely revolutionize
your work and as a result your life none
of us would want to work for a company
or invest our money in a company that
didn't have a very viable research and
development department if you're worried
about your income or your future you're
concentrating on the wrong end of the
scale those who insist on remaining
severe gear must expect to be jettisoned
when things get too rough for safety
success is really nothing more than the
progressive realisation of a worthy
ideal know your boss he's the customer
treating with the respect care and
courtesy and humor he deserves very
successfully getting the things we want
from life is a matter of solving the
problems which stand between where we
now are and the point we wish to reach
imagination is everything and we can
become what we can imagine
he was an American radio personality
writer respected speaker and author he's
considered to be the Dean of personal
development in the early 50s he was the
voice of Sky King and radio show host
with WGN he's Earl Nightingale and here
his top 10 rules for success attitude
has been called the most important word
in any language in the world because
it's our attitude toward our world
toward all the people in it that will
determine the world's attitude and all
the people's attitude toward us it's a
simple thing most of us won't but we
tend to forget it people will react to
us according to our attitude and our
attitude is the greatest gift we can be
given you know the little creatures of
the world were given a wonderful gift by
Mother Nature called protective coloring
in which they can blend into the
background without being seen but man
was not given this great gift because
man was given an incalculably greater
one only man has the godlike
to make his surroundings change to fit
him because his environment will change
as he changes a man's environment is a
merciless mirror of him as a human being
and if he thinks his environment could
stand a little improvement all he has to
do is improve in this environment will
improve to effect the changing man
there's nothing more pitiful to my mind
and the person who wastes his life
running from one thing to another
forever looking for the pot of gold at
the end of the rainbow
and never stay with one thing long
enough to find it
no matter what your goal may be perhaps
the road to it can be found in the very
thing in which you're now engaged you
see the average man believes some
businesses are better than others
instead of realizing the truth that
there are no bad businesses there are
just those people who don't know enough
to see the opportunities and the work
they're in no matter what our work
happens to be it's our business we're
the manager if there seems to be no
future or opportunity in it it isn't
always because it's not there but
perhaps only because we can't see it I
want to recommend that you take just one
hour a day five days a week and devote
this hour to exercising your mind pick
one hour a day on which you can fairly
regularly count and during this hour
every day take a completely blank sheet
of paper at the top of the page write
your present primary goal clearly simply
then since our future depends upon the
way in which we handle our work write
down as many ideas as you can for
improving that which you now do try to
think of 20 possible ways in which the
activity that fills your day can be
improved you won't always get 20 but
even one ideas good now remember two
important points with regard to this one
this is not particularly easy and to
most of your ideas won't be any good I
want to say it's not easy I mean it's
like starting anything you have it at
first you find your mind a little
reluctant to be hauled up and out of the
old familiar rut but as you think about
your work and ways in which it might be
improved write down every idea that pops
into your mind
how absurd it might seem let me tell you
what will happen some of your ideas will
be good and worth testing the most
important thing this extra hour
accomplishes however is that it deeply
embeds your goal in your subconscious
mind starts the whole vital machinery
working and twenty ideas a day to come
up with that many total a hundred a week
even if you don't think on weekends an
hour a day five days a week tolls two
hundred and sixty hours a year and still
leaves you three thousand seven hundred
and forty hours of free leisure time but
this means you'll be thinking about your
goal and ways of improving our
performance increasing your service six
and a half for extra working weeks a
year six and a half 40-hour weeks
devoted to thinking and planning can you
see how easy it is to rise above the
so-called competition and will still
leave you with fifteen hours a day this
appendage of please starting each day
thinking you'll find that your mind will
continue to work all day long you find
that at odd moments when you least
expected really great ideas will begin
to pop into your mind and when they do
write them down as soon as you can just
one great idea can completely
revolutionize your work and as a result
your life none of us would want to work
for a company or invest our money in a
company that didn't have a very viable
research and development department that
is pumping a good percentage of its
profits back into research and
development because its future depends
on it
so does immense you might ask yourself
how much you've your own take-home pay
have you spent during the past year for
materials calculated to make you smarter
this year than you were a year before
calculated to make you a little better a
little bigger as a human being there
perhaps would love a little more heat a
little less and do a little better job
than you did a year ago how much money
are you pumping back into yourself in
your future so we're thinking about our
rewards in life will always match our
service it's another way of saying as
you sow so shall you reap
and it's been written in many ways in
every language on earth I like to think
of this law in the form of a giant
Apothic
a scale one of the bowls is marked
service the other smart rewards now
whatever we put into the ball marks
service the world will match in the ball
marked rewards if any person alive is
discontented with his rewards he should
examine his service action reaction as
you sow so shall you reap what you put
in will determine what you must get back
in return so simple so basic so true and
yet so misunderstood if a business is
not expanding with a quick and exciting
tempo of the times it must examine its
contribution its service if a person is
unhappy with his income he must examine
and re-evaluate his service never before
in the history of the world have human
beings been so interdependent it is
impossible to live without serving
others as it would be the liveth others
were not constantly serving us in
thinking of ways of increasing your
service read books on your specialty
read what others have found to work well
for them but at the same time think of
original and creative ways of increasing
your service ways that are unique with
you and the way you are each morning and
during the day ask yourself this
question how can I increase my service
today knowing that my rewards in life
must be an exact proportion to my
service I do this every day and you will
have started to form one of life's most
valuable habits Horace Mann wrote if any
man seeks for greatness let him forget
greatness and ask for truth and he will
find both you see you can cut away all
the confusion and complications and
nagging worries and vague half-formed
fears by returning to the great truth
the great laws the great verities on
which all success all accomplishment the
whole world is built if you're worried
about your income or your future you're
concentrating on the wrong end of the
scale look at the other end concern
yourself only with increasing your
service with becoming
great where you are and your income and
your future will take care of themselves
the great steel magnate Andrew Carnegie
would ask the formula for success
answered put all your eggs in one basket
then watch the basket let's be frankly
realistic who gets laid off work during
an economic slump
well what gets thrown over the side when
a ship is in danger of going down
everything not absolutely vital to the
operation of the craft and the safety of
its passengers and it's the same with a
business or any other organization with
a corporation its main purpose is to
remain in business forever as long as it
remains in business it can provide a
needed product or service protect the
investment of those who have faith in it
and provide jobs for those who are vital
to its continuity of operation it's the
duty of management to protect the firm
and the people who depend upon it just
as it's the captain's duty to do
everything in his power to keep his ship
sailing all the pressur needs to do is
to make certain that he or she is a
vital part of his business or
organization those who insist on
remaining severe gear must expect to be
jettisoned when things get too rough for
safety nobody particularly the captain
likes to see cargo thrown over the side
but if it will help save the ship
there's something nothing else to do
that's why people are laid off it has
nothing to do with management and labor
relations or personalities and in the
long run it's best for everyone since
one smooth sailing as a young man
reached additional employment can be
made available so each of us must decide
whether we want to be part of the cargo
or a member of the crew most people
don't know what success is all about and
since they don't know what it's about
they really don't know what to look for
it success is really nothing more than
the progressive realisation of a worthy
ideal this means that any person who
knows what he's doing and where he's
going is a success any person with a
goal toward which he's working is a
successful person this means that the
buoyant in high school who's working
toward a diploma as a boy
College toward a degree is just as
successful with any human being on it
because he knows what he's doing why
he's getting up in the morning and what
he's going but conversely if a person
doesn't know what he's working toward
what it is he wants does never go toward
which he's working that he must at least
by this definition we called
unsuccessful
why isn't then with his simple
definition why isn't everyone successful
should be easy yet surveys indicate that
19 out of 20 95% at least are not in
fact a survey one time as thousands of
working men why they got up in the
morning and went to work and 19 out of
20 didn't know 19 out of 20 working
people didn't have a fungus notion of
why they got up in the morning and went
to work under closer questioning they
said well everybody works well that
would be a good reason to quit in fact
this little rule of thumb you might want
to remember whatever the great majority
is doing under any given circumstance if
you do exactly the opposite you probably
never make another mistake as long as
you live just something to keep in the
back of your mind the problem with most
people is that they're playing the
world's most unrewarding game and the
name of the game is follow the follower
as a story about a small town in which
there was a jewelry store like all
jewelry stores or most jewelry stores at
least he had a big clock in his window
and every morning for years he'd noticed
a workingman stop adjust his pocket
watch at the same time as a clock in the
window he'd been doing this for many
years and one morning the jeweler was
out in front sweeping his sidewalk and
so yes the man he said tell me why do
you just your watch to my big park every
morning I've noticed you're doing that
for years and that's where I'm the
foreman down at the big plant he said I
want to make sure my watch is correct
because I blow the quitting whistle
every night at 5 o'clock that you would
have looked at another strangely from
any symbol that's funny thing I've been
setting that big clock in a window but
it quitting whistle all these years
a very logical thing but they could have
been off six months it was a case of a
person just going along with what he
thought to be correct without checking
his references so I want to suggest it
from now on out at least we do that that
we check our references and ask
ourselves are the people I'm following
going what I want to go trying to find
some way every day in which your work
can be improved and above all no your
boss he's the customer treat him with
the respect care and courtesy and humor
he deserves remember that he pays all of
your bills every month he will buy
everything you ever owned he maybe of
course crude coarse ignorant selfish
conniving and a thoroughgoing Savage he
often will be and here it's more
important that you treated with all the
care and attention you can muster if you
don't and if you permit his attitude to
affect yours you're admitting that he's
the stronger person if you respond the
same way he conducts himself you're
admitting you're no better than he is
but most people are nice people they're
people like you and me you want to be
liked you want to get along who want to
be friends they have problems and
sorrows of their own of which were not
aware and they have bad days and
disappointments make sure that the time
they're with you is a high spot in their
day and they don't want to come back not
just because of your company but because
of you
successful people are not people without
problems they're simply people are going
to solve their problems and there you
have it living successfully getting the
things we want from life as a matter of
solving the problems which stand between
where we now are
and the point we wish to reach no one is
without problems they're a part of
living but let me show you how much time
we wasted worried about the wrong
problems is a reliable estimate of the
things people worry about things that
never happened 40 percent things over in
past it can't be changed by all the
worry in the world
thirty percent needless worries about
our health twelve percent petty
miscellaneous worries ten percent real
legitimate worries
percent in short 92% of the average
person's worries take up valuable time
cause painful stress even mental anguish
and absolutely unnecessary and the real
legitimate worries there are two kinds
there are the problems we can solve and
there are the problems beyond our
ability to personally solve but most of
our real problems usually fall into the
first group the ones we can solve if we
learn how we become what we think about
most of the time and that's the
strangest secret this is why thinking is
so vital this is why a goal is so
important because we will become that
this is why people who set goals achieve
them the trouble with men is not
receiving their goals they do that
it's an establishing them we must love
them we must help them we must serve
them because our whole success will
depend on our ability these things but
never lose our own individuality and our
identity by permitting ourselves to
become submerged in what has
historically proved itself to be little
more than a suffocating sea of
indirection and purposelessness if we
want to emulate someone fine but let's
be choosy in steps we follow it's the
only life we've got and remember to
think imagination is everything and we
can become what we can imagine
if you find yourself getting depressed
and down at the mouth as we all get once
in a while you might want to remember
this quotation by Dean Briggs he said do
your work not just your working no more
but a little more for the lavishing sake
that little more which is worth all the
rest and if you suffer as you must and
if you doubt as you must
your work but your heart into it and the
sky will clear and then out of your very
doubt and suffering will be born the
supreme joy of life believe it or not in
the days when we've come to nearly deify
leisure time we've almost lost sight of
the fact that virtually all our
satisfactions and rewards will come not
to our leisure but from our work and
don't forget the strangest secret we
become what we think about thank you
guys so much for watching I made this
video because boot camp actual asked me
to so this is famous entrepreneur that
you want me to pro prom next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of Earl
nightingales top ten rules meant the
most to you had the biggest impact leave
it in the comments below and I'll join
the discussion and one last thing my
personal goal now the channel is that
hit a million subscribers so what do you
think you can think of to help share the
video get it out there get more people
on here I really really really
appreciate your support thank you guys
so much for watching
can you believe and I'll see you soon